der absturz des waadtländers sap arena
am 19 oktober 2016 hat einen schatten
auf die exomars mission geworfen dadurch
trat der hauptzweck der mitte und etwas
in den hintergrund
die suche nach außerirdischen leben auf
dem markt auf die mission läuft nach
plan und konkretisiert sich immer weiter
der aktuelle stand bei ging zum science
fiction herzlich willkommen übrigens aus
köln heute
eigentlich wollte die landung dieser
ersten landeeinheit die generalprobe für
die landung des mars rovers der ex
tomaten doch die mit lang nach allen
regeln der kunst während des
landeanfluges hatten die sensoren
unerwartete netzwerke erhalten und
interpretierten sie wohl falsch die
folge die triebwerke wurden abgeschaltet
und kabarett liste nahezu ungebremst auf
die marsoberfläche total tragen
die generalprobe war so richtig schief
gegangen die wissenschafter spielten
damals viele fehlleistung herunter und
es gab heftige diskussion ob sich die
esa hier nicht zu viel vorgenommen hat
aber dieser versuch hatte auch sein
gutes die techniker werden jetzt wohl
noch mal verstärkt darauf achten dass so
etwas nicht passiert denn die exomars
mission ist eine der wichtigsten
missionen der europäischen
weltraumagentur esa so weit ist man
schon gekommen
trotz dieses versuches wurden dann auch
die mittel für die fortsetzung der
exomars mission freigegeben wenn die esa
möchten die chance nicht verpassen
vielleicht die erste
weltraumorganisation zu sein die
außerirdische pflegen oder zumindest
früheres außerirdisches leben im weltall
nachweisen kann
dafür wurde die expedition unter anderem
entwickelt jetzt wurden die landeplätze
für die mission festgelegt dabei war den
wissenschaftlern wichtig dass dort
früher wasser gab vor 4,3 bis 3,9
milliarden jahren waren die bedingungen
auf dem mars ähnlich wie auf der erde wo
damals leben entstand wenn er so lena
für maß zu finden sein soll dann an
solchen stellen ob der planung & more
quelles sind die finalen kandidaten
zudem bieten sie auf festen untergrund
wenige rolle und es gibt keine steilen
abhänge das ideale terrain also für den
mars rover der ex tomaten für uns an dem
finden übrigens zurzeit die
abschlussarbeiten stadt damit der 2020
für den start richtung mars bereitete
wird einmalige möglichkeiten bieten und
zum ersten mal bis zu zwei meter in die
tiefe des mars bohren können hat es dort
leben gegeben oder gibt es dort noch
leben sind die chancen dort am größten
ist unter der oberfläche mit einer
probebohrung aufzuspüren und auch der
exomars trace gas orbiter ist im
wahrsten sinne des wortes auf einem
guten weg schon bald nach leben in der
marsatmosphäre zu suchen
er befindet sich ja schon im mars orbit
aber noch nicht
genug um die am mars atmosphäre zu
untersuchen dafür wird er jetzt ein jahr
lang abgebremst der treibstoff an bord
bereich nämlich nicht für ein
bremsmanöver aus dafür kriegt orbiter
immer wieder nachts vorbei durch die
atmosphäre und wird so abgeschreckt
in einem jahr soll er dann von einer
elliptischen bahnen eine kreisbahn
gewächse sein in der er die atmosphäre
untersuchen kann er soll sich das methan
in der marsatmosphäre genauer ansehen
und herausbekommen ob es geologischer
oder biologischer herr gruppe von hier
können sie es bereits ab dem nächsten
jahr hinweise auf leben auf dem mars
geben wir halten euch darüber natürlich
auf dem laufenden
dafür bringt trotzdem die am besten hier
ein abo aufs auge und vergesslich sehen
genau auf die glocke und für den
unwahrscheinlichen fall dass er noch
keine fixe um abonnenten watt hier habe
ich euch die erfolgreichen videos vom
zum science fiction zusammengestellt
wenn er drauf klickt www die absoluten
highlights hier bisher verpasst hat
ansonsten gesund bleibt